moving on
for our main story tonight we're going
to talk about a product that is wildly
popular in this country but instead of
telling you what it is
i'd rather show you an ad for it i
promise if you have never seen this
commercial before
you will never guess what it's for mom i
think
chubby's been drinking too much milk
sometimes you just don't feel like
cooking so i've come up with new purdue
entrees
fresh complete entrees ready in under
three minutes well
that took a turn and what exactly does
jim perdue
think he's doing there that family
doesn't need one of your shitty frozen
meals
they need someone to expel the literal
devil from their demented guinea pig
perform an exorcism gym or get the
out of their house
the point is our main story tonight
concerns meat
it's what i technically am to any animal
above me on the food chain like a bear
or a tiger or if we're being totally
honest a medium aggressive pigeon and if
you're thinking okay
i know where this is going this is going
to be a grim story about the conditions
animals face in factory farms
you're actually wrong those conditions
are horrific but they do get talked
about a lot
this story is going to be about the grim
conditions humans are facing
working in meat packing facilities if
you ate meat today
it probably went through one of them and
meat packing is a highly consolidated
industry
roughly 85 percent of beef production in
america is controlled by these four
companies and more than half of the
chicken industry
is controlled by these four their
employees are extremely important
to this country's food supply and to
hear companies like tyson tell it
they're important to them on a personal
level too
we've all got the same end goal in mind
protect our team members
they're our most valuable asset they are
our family i said
earlier that we're a food company but
we're a family and that's genuinely how
i
feel and how we operate okay if tyson's
workers are their most valuable asset
than their workers are by definition
not family because let's be honest
nobody's family is their most valuable
asset if you're gonna rank everything in
life by how much you value it it goes
number one your phone
number two food water and shelter number
three judy dench she's a
treasure
and then and only then your family
that's
just an empirical fact but second it's a
little hard to take tyson's
workers rr family talk given this
stunning allegations made against
managers at this tyson pork
processing plant in waterloo iowa one of
the first to shut down when the
coronavirus raged
uncontrollably in the spring a
supervisor allegedly taking bets on how
many would catch the virus
according to the allegations the plant
manager of the waterloo facility
organized a cash buy-in winner-take-all
betting pool for supervisors and
managers
to wager how many employees would test
positive for coveted 19.
holy that betting pool might be the
most disgusting thing
ever created in a tyson factory which is
frankly saying something given that
tyson also makes
ranch flavored chicken chips a snack one
customer reviewed online with a note
disgusting i gagged in front of my child
that review is on tyson's actual website
now tyson fired seven managers at that
plant after that incident but it does
speak
to a larger problem in this industry
because while companies
have put out endless press statements
about the expense they've gone to to
protect their workers during this
pandemic
workers themselves dispute those claims
heavily and
they've been hit hard as of february
18th at least 57
000 meatpacking workers have contracted
the virus and at least 280 have died
but the broader truth is that the
treatment of workers in this industry
has been very bad
for a very long time so tonight let's
look at them and let's start
with how plants operate most feature a
series of long conveyor belts with
workers
packed closely along the line chopping
deboning or trimming fat
often at breakneck speed maximum
allowable line speeds in poultry have
actually
doubled since 1979 with workers
reporting averaging
35 to 45 birds per minute that is less
than two seconds
per bird that's fast in the time it's
taken me
to explain line speeds to you a plant
could have processed
five whole birds and look there's plenty
of activities that should only take two
seconds
checking the time clearing your throat
determining the worth of a total
stranger by how much you want to
them
hey i get it but safely butchering a
chicken
probably shouldn't be one of them and
thanks to this relentless pace
meatpacking workers have reported it can
be hard to take a break even to go to
the bathroom
which may explain stories like this this
is security camera video given to our
sister station from the smithfield
production line in virginia
in the video you see the employee in
front take off his gloves
company officials confirmed the man
relieves himself
under the production line then puts his
gloves back on and continues to work
the worker at the center of all this has
been suspended pending the outcome of
the investigation
that is disgusting well yeah it is
the combination of urine and pork is a
bit upsetting
it's one of the many reasons i have no
interest in seeing miss piggy's sex tape
but it is not just that that man
urinated under the production line is
that he was put in a position
where he may have felt like he had to
that is actually a problem
across the meatpacking industry oxfam
released a report
detailing exactly how grim conditions
can be for poultry workers
with one detail in particular that hit
this local michigan talk show
hard poultry industry workers are put
through such extremes that they're
denied bathroom breaks
many wearing diapers during their work
oh my goodness
i know that people need jobs and they
need to be employed but
to have to stand in your own stuff
yeah while you're working my mind is
racing while you're sharing those
details and thinking surely this is not
in our country
okay i get the shock there i really do
but the thing is
this is totally our country we live in a
nation
where hundreds of thousands of homeless
sleep on the streets people have to
launch gofundme campaigns for medical
treatment
and where george zimmerman can auction
off the gun he used to kill trayvon
martin a horrific story which by the way
your show actually covered in this
segment directly before that one so you
guys
have been doing a pretty good job of
showing how up this country can
be
and it's not just bathroom break issues
meatpacking has some of the highest
rates of occupational injury and illness
in the country in fact
in a recent three year period a worker
in the meat and poultry industry
lost a body part or was sent to the
hospital for inpatient treatment
about every other day and a lot of this
is down to
dangerous working conditions plants are
so crowded
a common injury is a cut from your
neighbor's knife
and those rapid line speeds can
exacerbate other problems such as
repetitive stress injuries like carpal
tunnel syndrome all of which
can leave workers feeling pretty
disposable i mean you got two thousand
homes an hour going through you're
covered with blood
feces urine it's easy to get hurt down
there
you're doing that same movement for that
same piece of the hog
and it's non-stop you know basically you
treat it as a human
machine look that is clearly terrible
nobody should be treated like a machine
unless of course
it is a fun machine like an immersion
blender i'd love to be treated like an
immersion blender you want me to stay in
a comfy drawer most of the day and then
occasionally
come out to robot a soup yes please
look at this point you might be
wondering how do companies get away with
treating their workers like this well
many strategically locate their plants
in areas with few other job
opportunities and
target vulnerable groups like former
prisoners refugees and especially
immigrants
for hiring roughly 175 000 immigrants
work in meat packing jobs in america
they understandably may be wary
about complaining to authorities about
mistreatment so
many workers are already operating at a
deep disadvantage on top of which
companies have been able to minimize
accountability by gaming the system for
instance
they are required to report serious
injuries to the government's worker
protection
agency osha but there is a simple way
around that
because you actually don't have to
report those injuries if
treatment stays at a first aid level so
what do you think happens
well as a gao report found plants simply
offer first aid treatments on site
rather than refer workers to a doctor
that same report found even workers with
severe injuries like fractures
weren't sent to doctors with one worker
who developed a muscular skeletal
disorder
making over 90 visits to the company's
nurse before being referred to a
physician
and the workers know the game that is
being played here
there's a nurse but she doesn't do
anything for you for example
when our arms hurt all she did was apply
bengay ointment and
sent us on our way it's not even worth
going i needed to see a doctor but they
refused me
and i asked i told him well can i go
down to see my own
orthopedics my own specialist my own
doctor they said if you do that we're
gonna fire you
look there are lots of good reasons to
fire someone
frequent absences poor quality of work
because they get a little racisty on
ambien
but wanting to see a doctor really
should not be one of them
and it's worth noting if you do have a
severe injury it can be very hard to get
relief
in theory you can apply for workers
compensation programs under which
injured workers lose their ability to
sue but in exchange
can get money to cover medical treatment
and lost wages the thing is
those programs are run at the state
level and paid into by companies
who've lobbied hard both to hollow those
benefits out
and make them harder to get just before
texas overhauled its workers comp system
back in 1989. one poultry ceo beau
pilgrim
tried to personally influence
proceedings in a pretty blatant way
senator bob glasgow of stephenville says
he's never been offered a blank
ten thousand dollar check not until east
texas chicken king bo
pilgrim strutted onto the senate floor
wednesday senator hugh palmer of fort
worth says pilgrim then slipped him
either a bribe
or an illegal campaign contribution well
i didn't think he was trying to give me
a christmas present i'll tell you that
yeah of course he wasn't because
christmas presents aren't typically used
as bribes
that is unless you're a child of divorce
here it is billy
a full-size motorcycle just like you
asked for i think you should have it and
if your mother doesn't
well that is on her she's a difficult
woman billy
and look just a quick word about beau
pilgrim here he co-founded a company
called pilgrim's pride and blank checks
to legislators
aren't even the most shameless thing he
spent money on during his life among
other things
he had this 37-foot bust of his head
installed next to one of his
distribution centers and
added this second statue underneath it
depicting him reading a bible
to his pet chicken henrietta he also
built this
hellacious mansion which locals referred
to as cluckingham
palace and which included among other
atrocities this absolute nightmare of a
bathroom that fittingly
has the exact colour scheme of a raw
chicken breast and
this nauseating foyer featuring a
painting of what appears to be
two peacocks above some chickens
while a perverted owl
just watches and it wasn't just bo
pilgrim fighting workers comp laws tyson
has taken a lead in pushing for
changes in workers comp in state after
state which have made it harder for
workers hurt on the job
to receive payments in fact in texas it
is now possible
for companies to opt out of paying into
workers comp entirely and essentially
write their
own rules for how much workers get for
their injuries
tyson does exactly that and when workers
get injured in their plants there
in order to get medical care from the
company they must first
sign a document saying they voluntarily
release waive and forever give
up claims arising from their injuries
now could you not sign that
sure but then your best bet to pay for
medical coverage
is to sue the company and that could
take
years and while texas does now have a
law giving workers 10 days
to consider signing the waiver before
then they could actually be pressured on
the spot
at another company an employee who'd had
both of his hands
crushed was persuaded to sign a waiver
with a pen
held in his teeth and look i know that
this all sounds
very bad and it does imply that
companies like tyson
don't care about the physical well-being
of their workers but that's actually
not true because they do seem to care
very much
about the physical well-being of some of
their workers
employees at tyson fresh meets corporate
offices in dakota dunes are getting out
from behind their desk
all right looks good guys and into a
healthy routine
every tuesday and thursday we offer an
on-site fitness class for any employee
who wants to come
we focused on stretching at your desk a
lot of us sit at a desk a lot of times
so even just getting up and stretching
just that little bit of movement
throughout the day helps too we had a
workshop on meditation
last week and it was pretty good
clearing your mind and relaxing
stuff you can do at work you know what
it's true
meditation is great for clearing your
mind you just have to
sit still focus on your breath and try
not to think about the local camera crew
that's filming a piece about your
corporate office culture that will one
day be uncomfortably juxtaposed with how
appallingly your company treats workers
in its factories now
are those thoughts going to creep into
your mind sure but just acknowledge them
and return to your breath namaste
now clearly the contrast between tyson's
corporate offices and their plants is
stark almost as stark
as the disparity between their salaried
workers over 73
of whom are white and their hourly
workers over 60 of whom
are black asian or latino it's just a
fun fact i'm throwing in there
for no particular reason now ideally you
would want the government to step in and
remedy some of what you've seen
unfortunately osha is woefully
understaffed
as of last april its number of
inspectors had dropped to a 45-year low
in fact
at current staffing levels it would take
osha 165
years to inspect every workplace under
its jurisdiction
and even on the rare occasions that
inspectors
do get to visit the plants the limits to
what they're allowed to do once they're
in there
can be genuinely ridiculous in the
southeast where
a huge proportion of the poultry
industry resides
there is actually a lawsuit that has
successfully prevented osha inspectors
from doing broader searches in poultry
factories
even when they know workers are getting
seriously injured
in one case an inspector was told to put
a box
over her head so she wouldn't see any
safety hazards in the plant
if she wanted to walk through the plant
to investigate a fire
okay not to state the obvious here but
put a box on your head
is not an instruction you give when
everything is up to code it's just
inherently suspicious right this way
inspector now if you'll also just please
plug your nose and spin around three
times
we can begin the tour and even when osha
finds violations their power to do
anything
is incredibly weak in 2019 the average
fine for a serious safety violation a
hazard
where there is a substantial probability
of death or serious physical harm
was just over thirty seven hundred
dollars meaning
it can genuinely be cheaper for
companies to run an unsafe plant and
occasionally pay those fines
than for them to provide a safe work
environment and
all of this came to a head last year
when the pandemic hit
companies corporate workers immediately
worked from home because it wasn't safe
for them to be in the office
but the plants were kept open despite
the fact
as you have seen it's nearly impossible
to socially distance on a line and when
workers
entirely predictably then started dying
the federal response was
characteristically weak after six
workers from a jbs plant in colorado
died from kobed
the company's total fine was just
fifteen thousand dollars
and for the family of saul sanchez one
of those workers
that understandably didn't sit well saul
sanchez worked for the company for
nearly three decades and never called in
sick a single time
he was the first jbs worker to die of
coven 19
and his family says his funeral costs
more than the fine this company is now
facing
it's a huge slap on the face and they
bring in over 50 billion dollars
a year and they get slapped with 15 000
that's what enables these companies to
not care
for their employees yeah exactly
that fine amounts to point zero zero
zero zero
three percent of jbs's profits last year
and if you find a company a fraction of
a percent of their profits
don't be surprised when they carry on
only giving a fraction of a about
the welfare of their workers
now legally i have to tell you jbs
claims that that fine and the
government's finding that they fail to
protect their employees from exposure to
covid is
entirely without merit not only that
they are even fighting the claims for
workers comp survivor benefits
from saul sanchez's widow and others
who've lost loved ones their argument
being
that the coveted infections were not
work related
although to be honest that's a hard
argument for them to land
given that the outbreak got so bad there
at one point they had to shut the
plant down
so what can we do here well at least for
the duration of the pandemic
osha should implement a federal
emergency workplace standard giving meat
packing workers
the right to social distancing and other
protections longer term
that agency needs to be rebuilt and
strengthened and it can't stop there
the usda should do more to ensure lines
move at safe speeds
and when it comes to workers comp we
should be setting a baseline
for what states have to offer because
otherwise the race to the bottom
will just continue and all of this has
to be done quickly
because things are critical right now
remember that tyson plant with the
winner take all betting pool
as of mid-december more than 1500
employees there
contracted the virus and eight died so
if tyson truly is
a family like they love to claim it does
seem to be
a pretty dysfunctional one and
when you take
all of this together the diapers the
endless trips to the nursing station
the injuries and the deaths you frankly
only need to take a peek inside the way
this industry currently operates
to draw a pretty simple conclusion that
is disgusting
yeah it is it really is